welcome back to new rockstars I'm Erik
Bosse and the Batman teaser give us our
first official look at Robert Pattinson
in the Batsuit in the cow in Metuchen
with director Matt Reeves tweeting test
footage with some interesting lighting
choices interesting music I know it's
less than a minute it's just a camera
test but we're already getting a ton of
information from daredevil Batman here
so let's break down everything we know
thanks to Twitter and another new rock
stars tweet around it swirly warning in
case any of my Batman predictions
that'll be tuned right and somehow ruin
the movie for you let's look at this
footage I have been loving how Warner's
DC films have gotten buzz started early
with interesting camera tests who teased
the looks of their films and their
characters as they did with Joker and
birds of prey in this case it's just a
simple look at Pattinson as the Batman
bathed in red light and ominous Imperial
March style music Pattinson as Bruce
Wayne definitely looks leaner than the
bulky Brucie's that Ben Affleck and
Christian Bale were now sure this camera
test was probably done early in
pre-production but there have been some
reports that Pattinson has had a bit of
trouble beefing up but that's probably
okay though since other reports that
suggested that Reeves story we'll follow
a younger Bruce Wayne not necessarily
Batman year one but maybe like his
second year as a vigilante and detective
so this being early on in Bruce's life
this could be his first prototype suit
now the first detail to note is the new
Batman emblems really just wings it
doesn't appear to have pronounced ears
it's actually pretty similar to the
original 1939 Batman in bloom but we get
a clearer sense of what this will look
like when you remove at the red lighting
so yeah now you could say this emblem
appears to be in metallic pieces perhaps
a removable battery but really each half
of it kind of looks like a split shaft
of a gun
one theory I really love is that this
could be the gun of Joe Chill the one he
used to murder Bruce's parents and now
Batman is using it as a chess piece as a
reminder to not kill now many are
comparing the music and the red lighting
to the opening credits of daredevil on
Netflix but as the music continues the
low piano notes give away two horns
evoke in Danny Elfman's Batman theme
Mantha seemed to Batman the Animated
Series Michael Giacchino composed this
original score and he said that he
already finished writing the main theme
of the movie this may be what we're
hearing here the camera moves up to the
face and the cowl and if you brighten
and adjust to the contrast that looks
like stitching on the cowl as if it's
made of leather above the eye holes are
pronounced eyebrows making this cowl
more of a theatrical mask and casting
the eyes more in shadow and actually
those kind of look like white covers
over the eyes now some are comparing the
suit the overall look to the look from
the Arkham games and the setting of
Arkham Asylum has been rumored as a
possible setting for this film but
before I continue with this plot Theory
thanks to our good friends at the ridge
for sponsoring this episode
the rage makes everyday goods to a
standard you don't see every day they
streamline your life by turning the
things you carry like backpacks chargers
and wallets into tools for a better
living their flagship product is the
ridge wallet it was launched on
Kickstarter in 2013 and now sits in the
front pockets of over half million men
and women my wallet used to be for like
napkins covered in scrolled conspiracy
theories it wasn't healthy but not
anymore guys this is their aluminum
while it's in a raw color now they do
have other colors including some very
flashy Tiki designs go check all those
out but all of them they're light
they're strong and this one has this
cool industrial chic vibe the ridge is a
minimal front pocket wallet that's
designed to streamline what you carry
every day it has 30,000 five-star
reviews and is a better way to carry
your cash and cards there's a lifetime
warranty if you love it free returns if
you don't it comes to titanium carbon
fiber aluminum and over a dozen
different styles and colors they also
have great backpacks and travel bags
with RFID blocking pockets and optional
device charging batteries get 10% off
today with free worldwide shipping and
returns by going to Ridge comm slash new
rock stars
that's ridge con slash new rock stars
and used to code new rock stars find the
link in the video's description okay
setting the Batman in Arkham could
explain why so many villains have been
cast zoe kravitz explained Selina Kyle
Catwoman Paul Dano will be playing
Edward gnashed in the Riddler Colin
Farrell is Blaine Oswald Cobblepot
penguin John Turturro is crime boss
carmine Falcone Peter Sarsgaard is
playing a new character listed as Gil
Coulson Gotham's District Attorney but
summer
are saying that he could be a Harvey
Dent two-face figure Matt Reeves has
described his script as a noir story one
theory that we have speculated is that
all these members of the rogues gallery
could be imprisoned within our combate
man now has to interview each of them
for clues on a new mystery figure he's
trying to hunt down kind of similar to
the plot of Silence of the Lambs others
have suggested an adaptation of hush a
story that involves several Batman
villains really a story that gives the
Riddler a very big role but we know that
there will be lots of action Pattinson
has been training in Brazilian Jujitsu
with instructor Regan Machado who worked
on John wick Pattinson also said that
his Batman voice is inspired by Willem
Dafoe's voice when they co-starred in a
lighthouse together Randy and out the
cast as Andy Serkis is Alfred Pennyworth
Jeffrey Wright as Jim Gordon and Jamie
Lawson as Belle array all a mayoral
candidate and Gotham so with this
political election backdrop the Batman
may have a similar focus at Chris Nolan
used for the Dark Knight a story that
mixes crime with political corruption a
story about the very soul of Gotham City
folks you really should join new rock
stars official discord to participate in
the unfiltered version of this
conversation
my super dark theory for where I really
want this movie to go and how daredevil
Batman really moves the blood around my
body to join this inner circle become a
patron today at patreon.com slash new
rockstars comment down below with your
plot theory for the Batman follow me on
Instagram and Twitter at da vas all the
new rock stars and subscribe to new
rockstars here on YouTube for breakdowns
of everything you love thanks for
watching
[Music]